داخل هذا المقر مقر المستشاريه الالمانيه
في وسط برلين يدور نقاشا حاما الان لاتخاذ
قرارا حول طلب بولندا السماح لها بارسال
دبابات ليوبارد الى اوكرانيا هذه الدبابات
الالمانيه الصنع لا يمكن لاي دوله اشترتها
من المانيا ان ترسلها من دون اذن من هنا
وفيما تتجه انظار الحلفاء الغربيين الى
هذا المقر على الاقل في الايام القليله
المقبله يزداد التشابك بين المستشار ونواب
من الحزبين في الائتلاف الحاكم ونوابا
ايضا من حزب المعارضه الرئيسي الذين
يتخذون مكاتب لهم على بعد الامطار قليله
في مقابل مقر المستشاريه في هذا المبنى
دعوات تصدر من هنا تحث المستشار على اتخاذ
قرار سريع بارسال هذه الدبابات الى بولندا
وتحذير من انه قد يتسبب بانقسام اوروبا ح
ثقيل على كاهل المستشار الالماني الذي
يتخوف من ان تتسبب هذه الدبابات بجرب
بلاده الى الحرب حمل ومسؤوليه يقول البعض
تاريخيه امام المانيا والسؤال الذي ينتظر
الجميع ردا عليه الان هل تكون المانيا على
قدر هذا الحمل ام انها ام ستتسبب
بالخزلاني مره جديده